hey guys my name is matt you're watching
code tech materials today i'm going to
show you my favorite way to do libraries
recently
and
yeah let's get into it if you watch this
channel you know i use vc package
manager a ton so on windows here
if we launch our shell and have already
set up vc package manager it should just
work and we can check out libraries and
kind of install them like you do on
linux
so let's say we want to find
the fmt library it's a small library
that will make for a great example
it's just for formatting strings and
stuff so you do want to have your vc
package manager up to date
i think i said in a previous video that
you know i had a whole script for
updating vc package manager that's fine
at all and you still do need to do a git
puller once in a while i guess you need
to be in the
uh the repo
so let me just go there and get it
updated
i'm going to change to my e drive into
source and then i think i have vc
package manager here
yeah
so that's where it is and then we're
going to get full
and just pull down the latest changes
looks like there are some changes but uh
just be aware that you need to have this
updated in general
so if you just install it once and never
do this you're going to run into
problems eventually all right so we're
going to use visual studio with the c
plus plus framework or with the c plus
plus workflow when we launch visual
studio
2019 community edition
and i'm going to show you
my favorite way to add
libraries because of course okay so
normally with vc package manager you
basically install them globally just
like when you
use linux and install something a
library you install globally i just want
to make an example here here's a linux
shell
and if you do like sudo
apt
i don't know what fmt's called here
let's do
app search first from t and see what it
finds
which one of these is the right one
there it is live
live fmt dev so on linux if you want to
use it you basically just install it
globally
like uh
sudo apt install
live fmt dev
put in your password let it install
and now you can use it on your linux
projects globally
and it's the same way that it
with vc package manager if you do an
install so let's close that
launch my terminal here so if you in vc
package manager here we go
install
fmt
it'll say it's already installed i have
my triplet set as x64 so that's the one
it tries tells you how to use it with
cmake using visual studio with their
build system
then it's automatically already set up
but if you don't want the global
libraries that's what we're going to
talk about here so you launch visual
studio
say you haven't set up any libraries any
triplets anything you just installed
visual studio and updated heard on
visual studio you installed vc package
manager and updated it nothing else so
let's go to create new project and i'm
going to show you both the ways i'm
going to show you with the cmake project
so let's do that first so i'm just going
to use the template here cmake project
i'm just going to call it uh
test1 cmake
create that project and it's going to
give me all the defaults
and here we are
so by default you have a top level cmake
file
and
you have a project level because you see
it doesn't add subdirectory for your
project here so here's the project one
very good now the only thing you need to
do if you want to start using a library
with your c plus plus files here
you basically need to do this stuff
let's go
project right here
change this link libraries to the right
name
you can do this fine package before the
executable it's fine so this is the way
to do it globally i'll explain the
problems with doing it globally like
this
and maybe these problems aren't a big
deal to you and if so that's fine
okay
so literally all we've done is we went
to this project the subdirectory file
and just added find package in link
libraries
that's all we've done
now we should be able to include
cappuccino it's uh fmt slack format
so that's grabbing it globally from the
vc package manager installs so yeah all
we had to do was have it installed via
the global method do the find package do
the target link libraries to it
and it should just work
we can now include it we've got a little
test here to do a print to make sure it
works the same startup item
build and we should get
don't panic okay so format's working
globally but what if
you upload github and someone else
downloads it and tries to build it and
it doesn't build because they don't have
format installed because you would say
hey this requires vc package management
and they'll be like fine but then
then they got to go manually over here
and install all your libraries which is
a pain
so what if i told you there's a way to
make these libraries automatic for your
project and nobody ever has to type in
what they need to install
so
i'm going to show you how to do that
now the the big thing here is you want
to add a manifest so you go to your the
top level your project
and add a new file and call it vcpg.json
and in this file
you need to have a few basic things but
basically what this file is going to do
is it's going to tell
it's going to tell your project or tell
vc package manager
what libraries it needs for your project
and if someone goes and clones this
later
and tries to build it it's going to
automatically grab these libraries so
the downside here is it saves these
libraries all locally
but the upside is it's now per project
so
what we do here is we put in
it does need a name so we're going to
put in a name now i've discovered that
this name means absolutely nothing
typically you just make it your project
name but it really doesn't matter
version string
there's a lot of other stuff these are
the required things you have to have a
name it has to be all lower case
you need a version string
this also
doesn't seem to actually matter at all
but normally i guess it would be the
version of your project for now we're
just going to like smash some keys
because who cares but you just have to
have those and the last thing the most
important thing is dependencies
in this
use uh the robot
brackets
and you start listing your libraries
here so fmt
that's the only one we're gonna
have here for now now this is going to
automatically grab it now if you've
already previously built
your project you have to delete your out
folder where it's got all your build
stuff otherwise it's uh it's not going
to work
so we'll hit generate here
see what it does it's probably going to
be fine it's probably not going to
complain yeah
it works fine
but
it's still using the global one it's not
actually using this json yet
so to to get it to use the json you
delete this folder if it exists
reruns cmake and if it doesn't pop up
you just make a change to one of the
files
like add a space delete a space hit save
whatever and then hit generate and it's
going to generate all this stuff again
and if you look at your output here it's
going to have a bunch of new info
this is the cmake output
it's going to say
that it
installed some stuff that it needs
now this goes off the
whatever you have your project set to so
we have it set to x64 debug it's going
to grab the x64 debug of fmt and it's
going to tell you the same thing you
need to add these find package target
link libraries we do already have those
i think it's over here
oh that's top level one we do already
have those
in here
i want to put them close together i
think it's just going to be easier to
read
and there we go
so we've done that required
and now it should work so if we just say
play here
it should still work
and there we go
now this is no longer using the global
fmt
so we could actually even go over to
here
and go bcd which manager
remove fmt
removes the package
because we don't need to install
globally with this method it'll still
work i guess we needed to do a fresh
build so let's let's add some more text
here and let it rebuild
there we go so even without install
globally this works fine because it's
getting it for the project
just based on this
dependencies and now i'm showing you bad
practice here and i apologize this
probably should match your project name
but i just wanted to show you that this
name doesn't actually matter
as far as just like getting the library
working and same with this string but it
might matter if you have builds and
you're uploading tests to some special
doc or something
so
you should still put in the right names
even if it doesn't matter now i want to
show you a few other things like what if
we add
the release so if you go up here i want
to manage configs and you hit plus
and then find let's find x64 release
there it is
select that one
we don't need to make any changes it's
got all the stuff already that we want
it's going to be a release build so we
can now close this
and now we can switch this to x64
release
select our startup item
and
it needs to regenerate cmake so what
you're going to see here
is it's now going to go if we go to the
output
it should install the release version
of fmt looks like we encountered an
error okay the entire problem here was
the name name does not like having an
underscore you can't have an underscore
in the name
or else
or else it will not give you an error
that makes sense
because well well welcome to being a
coder
where half the time the errors don't
make any sense
so okay let's go back to 64 release it
says switch configs
and let's go to a cmake have it generate
this thing and check out the output we
can see it's now getting the library
needs
fmt for release now x64 release
and it gets what it needs all right
so now we can build the release version
go to select startup item
run it
and there we go
so that's how you do it with cmake and
of course you can add as many libraries
as you need just put a comma
add another one comma add another one
and they essentially need to match
exactly what's in here
if you don't know the exact name of it
go to your your shell and do a search
burst
just search for whatever you need
and type in that exactly so that's just
another example of another library but
there's tons of libraries that you can
use here of course
now you'll notice i just want to point
out one last thing here if you go to
yeah the cmake settings json this is
where we're setting up these different
build types
you'll notice down here
that
under these variables
manifest mode is checked install mode is
checked so they basically have the
settings for you that you would want you
typically don't need to mess with any of
this you can just add the release build
like i did
if you want
all right so let's do a different
example let's say you don't want to use
cmake
and you just want to use the standard
visual studio build
because cmake doesn't work for you or
whatever
so you go create new project
empty project
yeah we'll just double click it
and we'll do uh
yeah we'll just leave it project one
or test that's fine
so i'm going to show you how to do it
here if you're not using cmake and
you're just using
the plain old
the build system that comes with visual
studio a little less portable
but it should be fine
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
here is i'm going to change this to a
folder view
and we can see that we have no files in
our project
now what we want to do here
is add that vc package manager or the vc
pkg.json
that's basically the first thing we've
got no output no error list yeah that's
fine so we don't have it doesn't start
you out with the main let's go ahead and
add a main
add
cpp
name.cp
and we'll include
iostream sure why not
we just want to make sure it runs
main
okay so let's just make sure this runs
this is debug x86 nothing special there
and we just want to make sure the code's
fine in project setup okay
so
the debug in x64 this matters for
pulling down live words again but what
we want to do here is add the json file
so we're going to go back to the top
level
add
where's file
okay so this project this is gonna be a
little different because it doesn't just
have a clean ad
you can add here
new item
but it's gonna try to give you stuff it
already
it's gonna like pre-fill out stuff so
it's a little less intuitive and there's
a few other things you got to know so
what we're going to do here instead is
we're going to open up the shell
you can open up the shell with control
tilde
and you can see we're at the root here
on the shell and we can just type in new
dash
item
and the name of the new item where we're
going to make this vcpg json
and there it creates it now we don't see
it here
because it's at the top level
so that's kind of the annoyance of doing
it this way in my opinion is you just
don't you don't see it easily but what
you can do is you can right click and go
to open file folder and explorer
and it'll open up this folder
and you can see it right here so you can
edit this
we're going to use
visual studio code because why not
and you essentially do the same thing
give it a name
give it a version
give it the dependencies now is the one
that actually matters here
and we're going to try the same library
fmt
and there we go so we can now save and
close this
we're going to leave this folder open
i'll distract the site
but now what happens
is let's say we try to include
mmt
format
this works but this
is probably using the global one
however it shouldn't
because we already uninstalled that i
think did we
yeah
well let's let's go like this
remove
fmt
and let's tell the triplet
x
86
debug
make sure that one's removed
because before previously we
uh
we removed 64.
okay so yeah remove that one now too
so now
this x86 one should not work now i might
need a refresh it might still detect it
for a minute or something no it's gone
it's already gone
there's no format here
all right we should get some squigglies
let me uh
put in some uh
some tests here
here we'll put that in there
and let's try to run it
we get tests we didn't get this format
print
let's add in a few more things i think
the build is failing and it's just not
the same so
yeah the build is failing
but it's not saying so because i don't
know they just don't tell you so if we
go over here and hit build
we should see one failed yes
and it is saying it cannot open include
file format format.h
and you might be saying but i added it
to this vc package manager thing why
isn't it working
well they don't have the manifest on by
default so what you have to do is you
got to go to your top level project
right click go to properties
you can also get to this from project
properties
and in here somewhere
okay i'm saying this wrong sorry
you got to do it on your project level
not the solution level
so on this one go to properties your
project and look for vc package manager
and use vc package manager defaults to
no so you want to change this to yes
apply
and now when we go to build
it should install this so let's go ahead
and do that
build build
and let's see what it does
error occurred
version oh
version was not a relaxed state so i
made a little mistake here the way i was
doing version
it should have been version dash string
in this case
there we go
so now it should work
it looks like it's doing its thing
detected x86 windows because that's what
we're set to up here
and it's building it
and it's going to work so you can use
this with cmake
build systems or
with the standard visual studio build
systems so
this is awesome because now someone
downloads it it opens in visual studio
it's going to have your project settings
of the manifest being on
and it's going to have
that package manager thing
it's going to have this and it's just
going to auto get their libraries now of
course they do need vc package manager
set up but that's easy and quick to do
so anyone should be able to do it you
don't have to worry about triplets this
way because the triplets just automatic
based on your build i already said that
but just wanted to make that clear this
just makes it a lot simpler
all right
well let me know if you have any
questions down below
appreciate you guys hopefully this helps
with you getting your local projects up
and running whether you're using cmake
or visual studio
there are other ways of course
but uh
yeah this way is
really great for setting up a new
project
and uh yeah just let me know what you
think all right i'll see you guys next
time peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you